does it still annoy you that the
perception is that you and can katrell
didn't get along in that show and you've
said a million interviews hey I have no
beef she has no beef with me I don't
know where'd that came for so where does
something like that come from no it used
to really confound me and and really
upset me because you know we were part
of a family of Sopranos and nobody ever
questioned the relationships of the men
on that show and no one ever said to
them did you hang out this weekend with
each other right did you give each other
Christmas presents or what was what
message did you sent was every day
perfect where people always desperately
hopelessly in love with each other no
but this is a family of people who
needed each other relied upon each other
and loved each other and this sort of
narrative this ongoing catfight it
really used to be really really not even
art it really upset me it was usually
about like bad behavior on the set and I
take very seriously my reputation like I
work really hard and I treat people well
and I have you know a work ethic that's
very meaningful to me and it's based on
the affection I feel for the people that
I get to work with and to suggest that
I'm behaving poorly or not treating
somebody well that's not you it's like
it's not it's not even like it's not me
it's so an assáááá that it would drive
me bananas